los sindicatos siguen en pie de guerra
contra la reforma de pensiones
presentada por la primera ministra Este
martes los miembros de la confederación
general del trabajo de la industria
petrolera francesa convocaron a varios
días de paro de sus operaciones este
jueves anunciaron que acompañarán la
movilización nacional del 19 de enero
pero también se manifestarán durante 48
horas una semana más tarde y tres días
seguidos a partir del 6 de febrero
importante a partir de ese día el paro
será prorrogable con la posibilidad de
paralizar las instalaciones de refinado
de petróleo disminuir el bombeo y
suspender los envíos de carburante
recordemos la huelga del otoño pasado en
las refinerías fue caótica para el
suministro de combustible en el país con
estaciones de servicio cerradas grandes
filas para abastecerse y desesperación
generalizada por si fuera poco a este
movimiento se suma el de los
trabajadores del transporte público que
limitarán al máximo las salidas de
trenes regionales líneas de metro y de
autobuses Los que planean suspender
clases y hasta cerrar por completo
algunos centros de enseñanza los
trabajadores de la salud que pudieran
también afectar servicios no urgentes
ante todo este panorama la primera
ministra Elizabeth dono pidió esta
mañana a los sindicatos responsabilidad
y que no castiguen a los franceses pero
su gobierno hasta el momento sostiene
que esta reforma es necesaria y debe ser
implementada